[Music]
good evening I'm Alexandra Rosen the
executive director of the long now
foundation and tonight is a special
night for a few reasons but the the
primary one is that we have started a
partnership with the SF Asia Society
and/or Northern California Asian Society
and that's how we have found this
amazing speaker tonight and we're going
to be curating a few talks a year with
them and I wanted to introduce Jack
wodsworth from the edge of society to
talk a little bit about that partnership
sander thank you very much I'm delighted
to be here representing not just the San
Francisco Asian society but the global
Asia Society we were founded by john d
rockefeller the 3rd in 1956 and he said
Asia will be important and we need to
understand its culture if we are going
to understand Asia it couldn't be more
important today and that was a vision
that I think conforms to long now we are
delighted to have the opportunity to
bring more speakers with Asian
backgrounds Asian flavor Asian knowledge
to these lectures and nothing could be
more important to us here in the Asia
Society in San Francisco to be looking
into a future as partners with long now
so with that thank you very much and we
know that age is going to be a very big
part of the future and the long now and
we're looking forward to hearing about
it tonight thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah you know the next speaker that the
Asian society is is bringing on to this
series is the famous Asian George Shultz
former secretary of state of the United
States these talks do get into these
kind of continental issues and one of
the speaker's a couple years ago was Ian
Morris a history professor at Stanford
whose book and whose talk was why the
West rules for now and the title of
tonight's speaker be sure my boo bonny
is Brooke that just came out I think
that are in the lobby house the West
lost it and the rest of that is Asia and
the process of basically taking power in
the world and he has been in the thick
of that and can speak from experience as
well as very interesting perspective
Kishore ma Bhavani
[Applause]
thank Thank You Stuart I must say I'm
very happy to be back here to see some
old friends and young friends and as you
know when you have a title with a
question mark has the West lost it I'm
supposed to keep you in suspense to the
end so that your least is sitting on the
edge of your seats you know to find out
what the answer is but I'm gonna give
the game away I'm going to give you the
answer at the very beginning so you can
relax and not worry about what the
answer is and the answer is no or more
or why currently not yet but I fear I do
fear that it may do so and that's why I
came up with this book which I actually
learned literally a week ago in London
so it's a very new book and I'll try to
explain to you why I wrote this book
because in many ways the West has done
so much for the world and indeed the
first part of my room I'm gonna divide
my remarks into three parts in part one
I'll try to explain why does the West
matter I mean why should we be concerned
about whether or not the West is going
to lose it or not lose it and as you
know at the end of the day and I'll be
using this statistic often the West only
makes up 12% of the world's population
88% lives outside why does it 12% matter
that's what I hope to answer and then in
part two I'll try to explain why I think
the West has gone off course and has
lost the strategic directions
what mistakes it has made and then in
part three to end on a optimistic and
positive note
explain why I think how I think the West
can still change course and at the end
of the day as a friend of mine who read
this book actually said Kishore this is
actually a love letter from you to the
West to say hey wake up you know the
world is changing so let me let me begin
with part one of my story why does the
West matter the West basically matters
because if the West hadn't succeeded if
it hadn't been the first civilization to
transform itself an Asian over several
centuries of transformation the
Renaissance the Enlightenment and the
Industrial Revolution all that amazing
transformation that the West did which
it originally in a sense kept to itself
it is fundamentally now shattered with
the rest of the world and the reason why
the world is today a much better place
than it has ever been is because of the
success of the West now and I say
something like the world it hasn't been
in such a good place there's a look of
puzzlement often especially to my
Western friends who as you know not
necessarily the most optimistic people
in the world today but let me give you
some data to explain why the world has
never been better
and in that sense I'm glad Stuart that
I'm speaking after Steven Pinker because
I'm actually going to begin by citing
something from him and actually I had a
very interesting conversation with him I
was just spent some time in Harvard and
I had a very good one-on-one
conversation with him and I gave him a
copy of the book by the way and I signed
it I say to a fellow lonely optimist
well this is what Steven Pinker says and
I quote in this book he says violence
has fallen dramatically today we are
probably live
in the most peaceful moment of our
species time on earth
he adds global violence has fallen
steadily since the middle of the 20th
century according to a human security
brief 2006 the number of battle deaths
and interstate Wars has declined from
more than 65,000 per year in the 1950s
to less than 2000 per year in this
decade now that's a remarkable reduction
in violence now I know you wake up in
the morning you read serious stories of
Assyria and fighting in Yemen and so on
and so forth but if you like a long term
look the world has clearly become more
and more peaceful now take another area
where clearly Humanity has been trying
to transform the world which is of
course in in trying to eradicate global
poverty and here again I'm actually
quite shocked people don't know how
amazing advances we have made in
eradicating global poverty and so let me
let me quote what Oxford's Max Rosa says
in 1950 not so long ago that's two years
after I was born in 1950 three-quarters
of the world were living in extreme
poverty in 1981 hero still 44% but by
2016 the share and extreme poverty had
fallen below 10% so in my lifetime the
number of people living in absolute
poverty went from three-quarters of the
world's population to less than 10% and
hopefully within my lifetime by 2030 the
National Intelligence Council predicts
you go to zero I emphasize this because
any future historian
looking at our time will say what an
amazing time that was from 1950
three-quarters of the world population
living in absolute poverty to 2030 to
zero now this is the biggest ever
improvement in the human condition that
we've ever seen we are living in amazing
times and I can tell you by the way
that poverty is not just about physical
deprivation when I grew up in Singapore
as a child
Singapore's per capita income was the
same as Ghana's $500 and I happened to
come also from a relatively poor family
in a poor Society in fact at the age of
six I was sent for a special feeding
program because technically
undernourished
as you can see today I'm over nourished
but I tell that story because if you
haven't experienced poverty usually
don't know how psychologically
debilitating it is to your soul you feel
helpless you're just clinging on to life
and you're trying to survive not quite
sure where your next meal next income is
gonna come and guess what
we've got rid of that that's an amazing
leap in the history of human
civilization and who did it the West did
it another example somebody else on
literacy max Rosa in 1800 there were 120
million people in the world that could
read and write
today there are six point two billion
people who were the same skill now that
was let me conclude I have lots of data
let me conclude the last one johan nova
of the cato institute notes if someone
had told you in 1990
that over the next 25 years world hunger
were declined by 40% child mortality
would have an extreme poverty would fall
by 3/4 zero told them that they were a
naive fool but the fools all right this
is truly what happened so we live in
amazing times so why has this happened
why has humanity especially in the last
30 years made this incredible
transformation and why did it happen
before and the simplest answer is that
the West gifted to the rest of the world
the best aspects of Western civilization
which the rest absorb and as a result of
that humanity left forward in such a
dramatic way now there are many you can
give many examples of the gifts that the
West has shared in one of my previous
books I think if I'm not mistaken I
spoke about it at the Asia Society in
San Francisco in my book the new Asian
Hemisphere I talked about the Seven
Pillars of Western wisdom that the West
shared with the world but in this book I
point to three enormous gifts that the
West made the first is what I call the
gift of reasoning now reasoning is one
of the most sort of commonly used words
but people don't understand how special
it is when you make this leap forward
and enter the world where suddenly you
can figure out you know through science
and technology through cause and effect
why the world works and how you can
improve the world and I can tell you
again
the advantage of being having my kind of
history and background is that I have
seen the world before the spread of
Reason and I have lived through the
change and I saw the consequences so let
me explain in a very personal way
I'm ethnically
a Cindy Cindy's come from sandwich is
now part of Pakistan but my family were
Hindus and so they were refugees from
this result the partition one of the
most bloodiest partitions in human
history and because of that my family
ended up as immigrants in Singapore but
the reason I tell that story is that
before my generation my mother my father
my uncle's my grandfather's my
granduncle grandmother's none of them
ever went to university none of my
ancestors the first person from my
entire family chain to go into
university was me I broke some order I
broke through you and my three sisters
didn't go to university I broke through
I fortunately studied philosophy Western
philosophy understood the magic of it
and understood how it transformed the
world now what's significant is that
after me
my generation virtually no one when the
university but the next generation below
mine
all my three children all my nephews and
nieces all the children of my first
cousins all went to university right in
that amazing you can see what a great
lead you make from a world where you
don't have any access to the kind of
modern education to a world where
everyone has access and that's what
happened again in the last 30 40 years
that's amazing
so the number of minds that have been
opened around the world by the spread of
Western education is quite amazing the
spread of reasoning has transformed the
world another gift
which I also attribute to the West it's
what I call the change in psychology
and here again I'll make it personal
when I look back at my parents and their
attitude towards life and they suffered
a lot in some ways their view was if it
happens life is fated you can't change
your life it's all written for you for
my generation as a result of Education
said no it's not fate we can change the
world we can make it a better place
we can have a better life when you can
take control of your life you can do so
many things and that's what hundreds of
millions billions of people are doing
around the world and last six last
example of a gift from the West and I
can again say this with some conviction
because my last job I was Dean of a
school of public policy for 13 years and
the last gift from the West what I call
the gift of good governance and here
again it's quite amazing people are not
aware what our fundamental
transformation has happened as there's
other West sharing good governance he
said again if you look at ancient Asian
history when you had kings and queens
and feudal rulers they believed that
they had a right to rule and never
thought that they were accountable to
their people right today every Asian
government believes that they are
countable to their people so what do
they do they improve the livelihoods of
their people in the national bill
thousands of schools for his children
countries in Africa will establish
clinics in all parts of the country good
governance is spreading
and transforming the world
this too is a gift from the West now
clearly I can go on and say a lot more
but it's very clear and the future
historian will see this very clearly he
was first the West that succeeded then
the Western civilization shed is fruits
with the rest of humanity and now the
rest of humanity has succeeded and a
future historian looking at our slice of
history will say this is where the
Western project to create a more
civilized world has succeeded and
therefore this should be a moment of the
greatest celebration for the West you
should all be very happy I'm serious I'm
not even kidding I'm dead serious
that you have changed the lives of
billions of people who are today even at
the very bottom experiencing a quality
of life that even the top 10% couldn't
even dream of having life expectancy for
most of human history you would die by
30 or 40 today around the world 70 80
amazing right so why is it why isn't the
West celebrating what's gone wrong so
this is part two of my comments and part
two is a story that clearly the West at
a time of the great transformation of
humanity has made at least three major
strategic mistakes and these strategic
mistakes have I think led to the
condition of the West today where you
get this sense of
depression uncertainty about the future
so what are the three strategic mistakes
the first strategic mistake you made was
at a high point in the history of the
West when you had one of your greatest
victories you defeated the Soviet Union
you demolish an entire empire without
fight without firing a shot a great
victory and also resolve the great
victory after a great victory comes
great hubris and you thought that you
had reached the end of history all you
had to do was to go on autopilot cruise
control carry on you won the rest of the
world has got to change the West doesn't
have to make any strategic adjustments
you succeeded you're number one and the
reason why that was a strategic mistake
is that you decided to go to sleep and
this is what future historians would
notice you decided to go to sleep at the
precise moment when the two largest
civilizations started to wake up after
200 years of slumber as you know China
woke up first in 1978 thanks to tongue
hopping four modernizations went on
so China woke up in the 1990s also is
when India woke up right and why is this
significant it's significant because
from the Year 1 to the Year 1824 1800
over the last 2,000 years the two
largest economies of the world were
always those of China and India
and it's only in the last 200 years that
Europe took off and America took off so
if you view the past 200 years of world
history against the backdrop of the past
2,000 years of world history the past
200 years of world history have been a
major historical aberration all
aberrations come to a natural end so
it's perfectly natural to see the return
of China and India what was not natural
is the speed at which they came back
give you one statistic in 1980 as a
share of the global GNP in purchasing
power parity terms United States share
was 25 percent China share was 2.2
percent less than 10% in United States
1980 you all remember the Year by 2014
boom China's share had become larger
than United States 34 years amazing so
they were going to wake up and guess
what at the moment when China and India
decide to wake up you decided to go to
sleep and so for you obviously your
puzzle this wasn't supposed to happen
you're supposed to remain number one
forever with the end of history but the
end of history unfortunately was the
moment of the return of history so you
got just the wrong advice and I say
somewhat cruelly in this book that
Francis Fukuyama's essay did a lot of
brain damage to many leading minds
leading them to completely misunderstand
world that was coming that's a first
strategic mistake
the second strategic mistake you made
was in the year 2001 what happened in
2001 normally when I asked what happened
in 2001
yeah and says of course 9/11 happened in
2001 and as you know 9/11 was a big
shock to the United States I was there I
actually was in Manhattan when 9/11
happened I was the Singapore ambassador
you and then so I could feel the shock
and it was a big event and it's
perfectly natural to be shocked by an
even and therefore focus on that
unfortunately as a result of that shock
the West didn't notice that something
much more significant happen in the year
2001 far more significant or far greater
earth-shaking significance and that was
the entry of China into the World Trade
Organization and by the way I'm not how
do you say trained economists but I can
tell you just from the basics of
economics that when you suddenly inject
800 that's a hundred million new workers
into the global capitalist system they
would of course be creative destruction
quite naturally new competition so you
should have anticipated that there will
be loss of jobs and indeed one economist
recently I think his named one of
Michigan's author a uto our google him
has come up with data to show how many
jobs have been lost in manufacturing as
a result of China's entry into the
global capitalist system it should have
been anticipated but you didn't
you had your strategic sites focus on
the Islamic world you got deeper and
deeper entangled into it
well something far more important what's
happening with China's entry to WTO and
if you want the simplest explanation of
why Trump happened it's quite simple
you didn't pay attention to the
challenges that your working classes
were having as a result of China's entry
into WTO big strategic mistake so what's
the third strategic mistake this
happened more recently and I can tell
you I am absolutely certain that future
historians will be amazed that something
quite remarkable happened in human
history in 2014 and nobody noticed and I
already told you what it was in 2014
China's share the global GNP became
bigger than America's and why is that a
big deal because for the first time in
almost 200 years a non Western power had
emerged and become number one and what's
even more significant in that year PPP
terms number one economy China Asian
number two United States in America
number three India Asia number four
Japan Asian what a remarkable
transformation from 200 years of Western
domination boom Asia comes back and you
didn't pay attention at all to that
change
and it's pretty obvious that when the
world changes so much you have to make
strategic adjustments and I can tell you
as someone who spends a lot of his time
trying to understand the world trying to
understand what the major strategic
developments in the world are it is a
source of great mystery to me that in a
country where you have the best
strategic think tanks in the world you
spend more money on think tanks in any
country in the world us you have the
best universities in the world you have
the best newspapers in the world and you
didn't even notice that history had
taken a big turn in the last few years
and while history had taken a big turn
you quedan in cruise control and kept
going straight and that's why the West
feels it is lost it's not sure where it
is heading because you haven't
understood that the texture and
chemistry of the world has changed
fundamentally when you go from a world
where only 12% were the active dynamic
citizens of planet Earth making the big
decisions forging the biggest
breakthroughs and then suddenly the 88%
has woken up and the world has changed
and he's going to change even more and
all your mindsets all your concepts all
your perceptions of the world are still
stuck in the 19th and 20th century which
I said was the era of great aberration
and therefore you have to fundamentally
change course in the 21st century if you
want to deal with a world that is coming
so in an effort to be
helpful to the West because I can tell
you someone like me with my life story
you know from where I came from if I had
followed my natural destiny of my uncles
and cousins and all I would never have
gone to university I've never had the
kind of Western education that
transformed my life my life has improved
so much
so I appreciate what the West has done
for the world so I do want to help the
West but as you know sometimes when when
you want to have one you only want to
help your friends you sometimes have to
provide bitter medicine and therefore
the bitter medicine I give is all with
the intention of helping the West so
what I propose in this book which I
grant to you by the way will not be
reviewed by the New York Times will not
be reviewed by any of the leading
journals I know this all the books I
publish in New York over the last 10
years each time trying to tell the West
watch out the world is changing three
books published in New York none
reviewed the New York Times
none review the New York Review of Books
it's very difficult to accept advice
that is so different so what is the
advice I give in this book I say why not
adopt a new 3m strategy three amps
doesn't stand for the Minnesota mining
company I think 3m s r 3m words
the first M is minimalist now what do I
mean by minimalist very simple for the
last 200 years the West has injected
itself into every Society of planet
Earth
initially as you know it was an unhappy
experience in the 19th century virtually
every corner of the world was colonized
by Western societies and when America
woke up it also began to colonize
colonize Philippines intervening of the
countries that was how you dominated the
world for 200 years the trouble about
dominating the world for 200 years is
that it then becomes a habit you get
used to you assume that it is your fate
your responsibility to manage the rest
of the world and to fix every problem
that is fixing because it's the
responsibility of the West and to be
fair as I've said many other things you
did were good for the world the world
has transformed itself strong societies
are emerging around the world but when
that happens you got to adjust to a new
reality and so why not become minimalist
in what you're doing and here again I
can tell you one fact that future
historians will gain marvel at why does
the West believe that it can some are
other miraculously on his own by selling
aircraft carriers planes bombings
transform the Islamic world and make the
world a better place
you know when you injected your hand
into the Islamic world it's not
surprising it's like injecting your hand
or Hornets nests and getting bitten
right and I say one of the things I say
in this book which is politically
incorrect he said I know you worry a lot
about terrorism and you think that
that's a big threat but how much of it
is a result of your interventions in
their lives when there be a backlash now
of course you say but if we withdraw
things will only get worse if we don't
intervene they all suffer let me tell
you one simple fact there's one part of
the world which actually has almost as
many Muslims as the Arab world that part
the world is Saudis Asia FAC Southeast
Asia by the way is the most diverse
corner planet Earth in my book the Asian
miracle which I could brought out last
year I say there are about 650 million
people you have 250 40 million Muslims
hundred ten million Christians hundred
fifty million Buddhists Mahana Buddhist
in eye on a Buddhist you have Tao is
your confusion is you have Hindus you
have even have communists Saudis Asia I
know what's interesting the last 20
years especially its 9/11 you've been so
absorbed in the Middle East and you
neglected Saudis Asia
guess what let's resolve you neglect of
Saudis Asia is now one of the most
peaceful corners our planet Earth
doing very well growing a 6% a year
already the seventh largest economy in
the world about to become the fourth
largest economy in the world I didn't
even notice how many of you paid
attention to ASEAN the Otten miracle
maybe some of you did
sure but we couldn't ask the average man
of the street lost yeah never heard of
it but you asked him over Syria yeah
I've heard of Syria yeah so I'm just
telling you this that the strategic
impulses that you had in the nineteen
and twentieth centuries to intervene in
other parts of the world may have been
justified may have been rational right
at one time but clearly not when the
world has changed and just this weekend
I was reading in the New York Times a
statistic that someone said about again
United States share of the global GNP in
PPP terms in 1945 it was 50 percent in
1985 hero 22.5% soon will be down to 13%
from 50% in 1945 to 13% so your share
the global GNP clearly has gone down by
75 percent has that change any of your
attitudes approaches to the world none
so as a friend I can tell you that
you're much better off adopting a
minimalist strategy it doesn't mean
disengagement by just means a more
prudent way of engagement with the rest
of the world and I must emphasize one
thing your gift of Education of
reasoning to the rest of the world is
still continuing to make the
a better place with or without your
intervention so be minimalist what's the
second M the second M is multilateral
and I know the word multilateral is
designed to put an audience to sleep
whenever you talk about United Nations
global governance people's eyes begin
closing what a boring subject but guess
what
what will save the world is
multilateralism why because the one of
the results of the amazing
transformations that the West has gifted
to the rest of the world in the last
thirty years is that you have completely
transformed the world in fact in my book
the great convergence I use a simple
board metaphor to explain how the world
has changed in the past when 7.3 billion
people live in hundred ninety three
separate countries it was as though they
were living in hundred three separate
boats but captains and crews to take
care of each boat and rules to make sure
that the boss didn't collide but as a
result the world having shrunk the 7.3
billion people no longer live in hundred
ninety three separate boats the 7.3
billion people live in hundred and three
separate cabins on the same boat but the
problem about global board is that your
captains and crews taking care of each
cabin and no captain crew taking care of
the global boat as a whole and if you
want to understand why we are having
global problem of the global problem of
the global problem it's because we
haven't woken up to the fact that we are
in the same boat that's why we're having
global warming that's why we're having
global financial crisis that's why we're
having global pandemics that's why we're
having global terrorism it's a small
interdependent world and this is the
time when clearly we need to strengthen
institutions or global governance
and fortunately this is a gift from the
West in 1945 you gave the world a
wonderful set of multilateral
institutions I talked about in the book
United Nations I am F well bang well WTO
gives from the West and what have you
been doing
you've been undermining these gifts you
know I've been ambassador three UN twice
from 84 to 89 and 98 to 2000 four and
when I was ambassador you and I just
couldn't figure out why is it that the
United States which gifted the United
Nations to the world spends so much time
trying to weaken or undermine the United
Nations that's against global interests
indeed against Western interest too but
that's what you've been doing at a time
when we need to strengthen our
institutions or global governance
you've been undermining them and
precisely at the moment when you need a
stronger WTO you start a trade war and
you say trade wars are good and our time
we need to strengthen the United Nations
you appoint John Bolton as your National
Security Advisor I mean that guy is so
ignorant about the world he lives in a
bubble a small mental bubble that never
thinks about the seven other billion
people on planet earth again a future
historian wonder how could you do that
how could you not realize that this is
the moment for stronger multilateral
institutions but my third M is the one
that you will probably feel the most
uncomfortable with
M stands for the word mark your valiant
strange I'm actually advising the West
to be more Machiavellian and I know I
did a whole course on Machiavelli when I
studied philosophy I know that
Machiavelli is a figure very
controversial figure in the West in fact
the great American political scientist
Leo Strauss and I quote Leo Strauss in
this book describes him as a figure of
evil right but I can recommend to you a
wonderful essay written by the great
British liberal philosophers Isaiah
Berlin very well-known philosopher and
it's an essay on Machiavelli in the New
York Review of Books and in that essay
Isaiah Berlin explains why Machiavelli
is one of the most misunderstood persons
in the world
his goal was actually to promote vet you
vir tu I guess the best English
translations virtue and to try and
achieve the right good outcomes and
that's why Machiavelli is still relevant
and indeed if the West wants to find its
way again in this different world it may
be better for it to be a bit more
Machiavellian so let me give one example
of a Machiavellian advice and this
advice was given by President Bill
Clinton in a speech he gave at Yale
University in 2003 I'll read it to you
and I'd be curious to see whether you
think it's Machiavellian this is what he
said if you believe that maintaining
power and control and absolute freedom
of movement and sovereignty is in an
absolute freedom woman movement freedom
of movement and sovereignty is in
your country's future there's nothing
inconsistent in the US continuing to
behave unilaterally the US is the
biggest most powerful country in the
world we've got the juice and we're
gonna use it then he has a but but if
you believe that we should be trying to
create a world with rules and
partnerships and habits of behavior that
we would like to live in when we are no
longer the military political economic
superpower in the world then you
wouldn't do that it just depends on what
you believe and Bill Clinton by the way
is the only American politician who has
the courage to say in public what no
American politician can say that America
is going to become number two hey wake
up you know baby number one forever so
what do you do when you become number
two so clearly it is in America's
national interest as he says to live in
a world where the next number one place
by the rules
place by multilateral rules multilateral
partnerships and this is where Bill
Clinton was being very cunning he was
saying that if we won China if you want
to slip on the handcuffs of
multilateralism on the China what we do
we slip the handcuffs of multilateralism
on ourselves first on United States and
then when China becomes number one you
pass on the handcuffs to number one and
say hey this is how the number one
behaves it's so simple it's so clear he
gave the speech in 2003 not one American
paid attention to it no one has ever
cited that speech or Menten - mentioned
that speech again it's so simple
so clear and clearly this is the moment
to do so so at a time if you listen to
Bill Clinton this actually actually
reinforces my point that America should
be pushing for stronger multilateral
institutions instead you're undermining
them and when you do so so for example
let me give another example when you
ignore the United Nations right when you
learn when you unilaterally intervene in
parts of the world you justify it by
saying you know what this is a struggle
and this is what nikki Haley would say
in the UN this is what Samantha power
would say the UN this is a struggle
between the freedom living countries of
the world and the tyrannies of the world
Russia and China who of course will
support dictators like Assad so when you
paint it in black and white terms your
white the rest is black now let me give
you an example to illustrate why you
have to get rid of that black-and-white
view of the world because if you say
this is a struggle within the
freedom-loving democracies in the world
and the tyrannies of the world fair
enough which is the world's largest
democracy India which is the world's
second largest democracy Unitas America
which is the world's third largest
democracy Indonesia do you want to hear
what the other democracies are saying
you think them using their views matter
okay let me tell you what an Indian
official has said about your practices
of unilateral intervention in the rest
of the world he says in most cases this
is shams Iran in most cases the
post-intervention situation has been
rendered much worse the violence more
lethal
and the suffering of the people who are
supposed to be protected much more
severe than before
Iraq is an earlier instance Libya and
Syria other more recent ones a similar
story is playing itself out in Ukraine
in each case no careful thought was
given to the possible consequences of
intervention so this is the world's
largest democracy speaking think twice
be careful and if you look at your most
recent case you have intervene in Iraq
twice the first time was in 1990 under
the presidency of George HW Bush what
did you do before you intervene George
HW Bush sent n voice to over hundred
countries around the world got the
support of hundred countries they all
join in you are a spectacularly
successful intervention in Iraq 2003 you
tried to get the same support the world
said no don't do it I was an ambassador
the UN at the same time at that time you
couldn't get a Security Council
resolution so Kofi Annan said your
intervention was illegal you went ahead
unilaterally and look at the consequence
so you can see that in a world that has
changed you have to change and adapt
your impulses and if you do so you'd be
good for you and also good for the world
so this is actually I know many of you
feel that we live in a dark difficult
trouble place actually the truth is the
exact opposite we live in a moment of
the greatest historical opportunity to
create an even better world and future
historians looking at our time will say
this generation brought us to the verge
of utopia in improving the human
condition
all you have to do is complete the next
lap and our work would have been done
but to do that please change course
thank you
that's great thank you yeah most your
remarks were properly since you're in
the u.s. addressed to the US behavior
the West for quite a long time has been
transatlantic and if this was a European
audience what would you be saying well I
can I do have a lot about Europe well
you're absolutely right because I'm
speaking to an American audience I focus
in America I did I did get launched this
book in London and in Amsterdam and I
focus on Europe and and I think Europe
is also making similar strategic
mistakes I think the Europeans have been
very unwise and also as you know I mean
this is just a recent instance when they
when they remove the government of
Gaddafi in Libya
you saw the consequences the flutter
board people that entered into Europe
and so my advice to the Europeans is
very simple
Joe politics at the end of the day is
about geography so when the United
States intervenes in the Islamic world
the United States by and large is
protected by two big oceans Atlantic
Ocean Pacific Ocean Europe is not
protected by any big oceans from the
Islamic world so it is in Europe's
interest to participate in the calming
of the waters in the Middle East
instead of roiling the waters in the
Middle East and by the way I am actually
I must emphasize this fact since I come
from Southeast Asia I actually believe
that the Islamic world can succeed and
modernize on its own and it will do so
you may take a bit longer but he will
succeed so Europe should be
participating in the efforts to
modernize that world and not get
involved in trying to bomb the countries
and start wars in that
the world so that's my first piece of
advice my second piece of advice to
Europe just to give you an example of
geography Europe's long-term strategic
challenge unlike Americas is not China
Europe's long-term strategic challenge
is going to come from Africa and you
know why in 1945 at the end of World War
two
Europe's population was twice that of
Africa's today Africa's population is
more than twice that of Europe's by 2100
Africa's population be ten times the
size of Europe four billion to four
hundred million now surely it is in
Europe strategic interests to promote
development in Africa and you know the
best partner for development in Africa
will be China
mm-hmm and so Europe should be working
with China to develop Africa to protect
its long-term interests but but you
notice that the Europeans join in the
American chorus of disapproval of what
China is doing what your what China is
doing in Africa so the Europeans
basically my message to them is you've
got to start thinking independently and
develop your own perspectives understand
your own geography understand your own
environment and adapt to it with the
Europeans having done yet a couple of
questions about basically the Asian side
of all of this and the vs what are the
top gifts from the east both
historically and in in current times
gosh that would take another lecture I
think what we going to see I mean one
one reason by the way I can tell you I'm
70 years old now I'm actually very
excited to be alive as an Asian at this
point in history because in the last
thirty years of my life I have
personally directly
seen the Asian economic Renaissance it
happened in my lifetime I'm very happy
but after an economic Renaissance there
comes a cultural Renaissance and you
know I am amazed I never thought I would
see this explosion of cultural
confidence on the part of my Asian
friends they look at the world so
differently today so much more confident
and so much more interest in their past
heritage and culture so the great
rediscovery of Asian cultures of Chinese
civilization Indian civilization all
will come there'll be an incredible
explosion cultural explosion happening
and it'd be good for the world and you
will make the world a much richer place
and you know you can it can be things
like by the way as you know Prime
Minister Modi to give one concrete
example if I'm not second I start of a
ministry for yoga if I'm not mistaken am
I correct yeah so yoga is something that
would be Indian gift to the world the
Chinese as you know are rediscovering
some of the virtues of Chinese medicine
and as you know one of the virtues of
Chinese medicine is that you take a
holistic view of the body and you try to
do something in that lines something of
that so all all kinds of new things will
surface but at the same time I will also
emphasize that all the Asian countries
sang the West for the gift of Science
and Technology that you're given to them
a question from Liz bowler what is
surprised you most about Asia's rise
over the past decade or so so you were
there too thick saying all this is
anyone saying it for a while yeah yeah
and when he be thinking of a said to you
sort of on track with what you expected
25 years ago or their surprises a long
way still I I would say number one the
speed has surprised me I mean I I
frankly if you even if you had asked me
1990 let's say when I started writing
all these things I don't sa call the
west and the rest in 1992-93 I would
never have anticipated that China's
share the global GNP will become number
one by 2014 that was a complete surprise
to me and and then I would say that the
Southeast Asia right which everyone as
you know is described as the Balkans of
Asia as emerges one of the most peaceful
corners for the world in fact Southeast
Asia by the way has the second most
successful regional organization in the
world after the European Union and
nobody knows most of most in the world
haven't heard of it that's why it was
called the Austrian miracle and you
promote that say more about it yeah
because you know if there was one part
of the world that was supposed to break
up and become like the Balkans and and
to create more Yugoslavia's it should
have been Southeast Asia and Indonesia
for example is an amazing story because
in 97 98 Indonesia went through a
wrenching this is only 20 years ago
wrenching financial crisis and at the
height of the financial crisis I must
say that I shed the conventional wisdom
in 97-98
that Indonesia could break apart like
Yugoslavia not if you had told me in 97
98 that Indonesia would then emerge as
the most successful democracy in the
Islamic world twenty years from now I
said no no way but it happened this is a
real you know in the Indonesian story so
it's a real miracle why wouldn't it
break up and yes it's not even a comment
in Tunisia is scattered it's denied
several thousand islands and it's a
country that's designed to be easily
broken up and it's ad separatist
movements and I can tell you in one of
the most unfair things that I've ever
seen in human history
you know when president SBY susilo
bambang yudhoyono
of indonesia and his deputy use of color
managed to achieve peace in our che now
the conflict in our chief or your
informations been going on for long
time you know several centuries they
finally produce peace in Aceh and what
the Nobel Peace Prize kept Peace Prize
Committee do they give the Nobel Peace
Prize for Peace in Aceh to a Finnish
gentleman another friend of mine Matti
Ahtisaari but they should have given it
relations and that's what I mean people
don't notice it when the Asians do
remarkable things you just end up giving
Peace Prizes to fellow Europeans and you
forget sedation to accomplish this
well the Nobel Prizes are sort of done
in Europe earth could come from
somewhere else and maybe I should marry
cave Magus dad who is a journalist he's
worked in China for a long time yes
what's a plausible future in which it
turns out this is not the Asian century
how could a ship blow how could a ship
lloyd well she could blow it in several
ways if you ask me my biggest concerns
my number one Z by 2050 you know the
world's most important geopolitical
relationship is always without exception
between the world's number one power and
the world's number one emerging power
today is the world's number one powers
United States still comprehensively the
worst number one emerging power in China
so that's the most important
relationship twenty years from now the
world's number one power be China the
world's number one emerging power will
be India aha so the China India
relationship could end up very badly and
therefore it's very important for China
and India to manage that relationship
well and unfortunately when I was in
India in January this year I noticed a
significant rise of what I call
anti-china sentiment in India and and
that that that worries me so you asked
me am I worried about that I'm worried
about that but if you ask me will there
be war within China and India I take
bets with you there'll be no war within
China and India they actually have
managed it that border quite well
no shot has been fired for
forty years or so I guess it helps if
the border or sort of unpleasant
mountains to know actually if you look
at the border within India and Pakistan
is equally mountainous by their shooting
but you say there's this sort of anti
Chinese thing in India now based on what
what are what are they arguing about
well I think there is there's a feeling
in India that China is moving
aggressively in its neighborhood right
that China is establishing close
relations with Sri Lanka with Bangladesh
of course in Pakistan sorry they're
building a big port in Pakistan yes yeah
and and and and by the way it's actually
a good thing that China is building this
infrastructure whether we infrastructure
is that not a zero-sum game you know
infrastructure is actually good for the
for the reach for the country for the
region and for the world and of course
sometimes you end up with mistakes like
as you know the Chinese build a huge
spot in Sri Lanka that has become a
white elephant now yeah and that white
elephant unfortunate becomes China's
burden so China's going to be very
careful what happened now they the it's
a it's a long and complicated story but
they thought they thought they could
sort of compete with Singapore and they
didn't realize how good Singapore
Singapore is exceptionally good in terms
like port services and all that I mean
we are number one in the world I'm sure
you know this so it's very difficult to
compete with Singapore this may be a
good point your Singapore the world in
Singapore is a sort of people have a
kind of a vague idea about something
kind of benign the kind of autocratic
and Disneyland the death penalty or
something like that and
I think the the the role of Singapore in
Asia is much more key than most people
recognize but what's your perspective
from within Singapore of that yeah well
III would say that Singapore has changed
a lot you know what ended in part of its
geniuses yes the one from platform to
platform yeah and and and one of
Singapore's biggest contributions I
suspect when future historians look at
Singapore's role in Asian history its
them they might say that it was
Singapore that was the first Asian
country to absorb what I call the
Western virus and then share that
Western virus with his region and let me
tell you one story that brings his home
and I can say this now because one of my
very good friends was the lead foreign
minister of Indonesia his name was Ali a
lathis was his name and he and I became
good friends because he he was the
Indonesian ambassador to the UN when I
was a Singapore ambassador to the UN and
he told me an amazing story you know he
said Kishore for many years Indonesia
would send its urban planners to Europe
so they would go to Amsterdam they'd go
to Zurich they'd go to London they go to
Paris and then they will come back
they'd write report how wonderful urban
planning is in Amsterdam or London that
they come to last paragraph and then
they would say but Amsterdam is in
Europe Jakarta is in Asia we in Asia
cannot do what the Europeans can do sign
report filed away he said one year my
whatever whatever reason they send their
urban planners to Singapore they came
back and they wrote a report about how
wonderful urban planning in Singapore is
and by the way Singapore you know I'm
chairman of the Lee Kuan Yew world city
nominating versity price nominating
committee so I've studied cities around
the world Singapore is clearly off the
charts in terms of urban planning okay
it's amazing so the in donations came
saw this
they went back they wrote a report and
they came to the last paragraph and they
said but Singapore is in Europe Hey
Singapore no in Europe Singapore is in
Asia and he said that's the first time
they realize hey maybe we can do it too
and she you if you haven't lived through
a psychological mindset where you felt
helpless and you couldn't change things
you really don't understand why it's
like when you suddenly change your
mindset you say hey I can do it too and
that's why I mean I I tell you one of
the most impressive leaders I met is the
present president of Indonesia Joe Kobe
and before he became president he was
what you call the mayor or governor of
the capital city Jakarta and before he
ran for president he actually invited me
to travel with him in a jeep as a driver
and he and I sat behind someone
interpreting for us in front and he
showed me he took me around the city to
show what he was trying to do in Jakarta
hmm and then he told me came to a spot
he said sure you see that see those
slums over there our dream is to build
Singapore style public housing in that
area so what we have done in Singapore
has been a source of inspiration for
many and by the way I'm sure you know
this China has learned so much from
Singapore Deng Xiaoping users say go
learn from Singapore we have actually
hosted in Singapore I would say
thousands of mayors from China and so
Singapore is small that it is has
actually made a fundamental
transformation and just to complete the
story let me tell you another story
you know Ratan Tata is one of India's
most famous industrialists a man of
great integrity and he said you know for
many years he would try and persuade
his fellow Indians why don't we go to
Singapore and learn from Singapore and
his fellow Indians would say huh
Singapore is so small India is so big
what can big India learn from Singapore
and he said China took off he told his
fellow Indians you see the Chinese
learned from Singapore see where they
are we didn't learn from Singapore see
where we are this is from an Indian so
this and this gets burnt terms of the
question of sort of the autocratic role
in an emerging nation basically and and
also the city aspect which interests me
a lot because Singapore is basically a
city staying even more than Venice was
in some respects because it doesn't have
much else besides the city and the
people of the city but Lee Kuan Yew is
this
I think astounding character and
personality and force in the 20th
century primarily to basically design
and build with great cunning as you
pointed out of the Singapore example
which was a new kind of example in that
century which is as you say continuing
into this century this is kind of one
guy telling how it should be done and a
lot of people you and many others
realize the genius of it and went along
and then made that a patient so it kept
moving through time but Singapore was
not famous for its democracy say the way
India is famous for its democracy so
there's questions that are in their
stack as you can imagine saying what's
the role in democracy of all of this is
democracy a different thing in Asia than
it has been in the West
hmm well I actually I have discussed
this in the book and also elsewhere and
I would say that I actually believe in
the long run all societies are going to
become democracies I mean that they no
doubt and and what's interesting about
the Asian story is that India is
succeeding
it's a democracy mm-hmm China is
succeeding is not a democracy right
right and so but they're succeeding
differently yeah yeah there's a time at
least when sort of Asia Watchers here
we're saying well it's going to be a
race between China and India who's gonna
you know rise fastest and clearest and
cleanest or whatever and that's not an
answer
China rose fastest but as far and yeah
but I think it's also fundamentally a
major misunderstanding of China in this
country say more and I let me tell you
what the major misunderstanding is you
all you've seen that China was ruled by
Communist Party in 1949 a common rule by
Communist Party in 1979 it'd be ruled by
Communist Party 2019 and you assume that
China hasn't changed is still being run
by the same Communist Party but the
Chinese Communist Party has obviously
changed fundamentally I mean from and I
I went to China for the first time in
1980 when I went to China for the first
time in 1980 the Chinese people couldn't
didn't have the freedom they couldn't
choose what to wear they all wore Maori
suits they couldn't choose where to live
where to work what to study
then suddenly zero Chinese could travel
overseas zero now you go back to China
the Chinese people can choose what to
wear where to live where to work where
to study and guess what every year
hundred and twenty million Chinese right
think it's more than population in
California 120 million Chinese leave
China freely as tourists amazingly 120
million Chinese returned to China freely
now if China was a communist gulag
Stalinist aid would you go back to China
and so there's a complete
misunderstanding of China clearly there
while the political freedoms in China
have an increase the personal freedoms
of the Chinese people has exploded and I
can tell you one of the one of the
questions that future historians will be
very puzzled by is the judgments made by
America on China and I tell you why they
be Puzzle the United States of America
is about 240 years old Chinese history
maybe two thousand four hundred years
old in today's world you have a society
which is two hundred and forty years old
passing judgment on a society which is
2400 years old and at a time when China
has had its best 30 years of history
the Americans are telling Chinese you
guys are not doing very well really you
should change your political system
listen to us become a democracy all we
well with you and I can tell you one
thing that Chinese leaders there's a
whole shades of opinion among them the
one complete point of agreement that
they all have is that they saw what
happened to the Soviet Communist Party
they saw what happened to the Soviet
Union they saw what happened to Russia
he went overnight to a democracy guess
what the Russian economy imploded life
expectancy came down infant mortality
went up the Russian people suffered and
the Chinese said this is what happens
when you have an instant democracy so
when the Chinese said give us time let
us transform our political system when
our own will I said let them do it why
do you think that you would know better
what's good for them does that reflect
the fact
that for 200 years you got used to doing
it telling the world how they should
behave and therefore you think you can
be a better judge of the rest of the
world so that judgmental character in
the West has got to adapt to a rest of
the world because the rest of the world
today is less willing to be judged by
you so how much of this China
sensibility is awareness of what was
going wrong in Russia another communist
country sighs close neighbor what was
going right in Singapore that kind of
attention outside the sort of national
it's a very nationalists with all of
that history very aware of China is the
Middle Kingdom yes they had this
awareness looking out and where I'm
going with this is the Politburo seems
to have been made up by so many
basically technical leads people from
the engineering and scientific
background probably more than in the
governmental leadership than any other
country in the world that I know of
democratic countries for whatever reason
don't elect scientists and engineers so
much so is that part of the dynamic that
made China this perceptive this capable
of sort of changing things in a peaceful
way in an adaptive way yes in fact I I
just gave a lecture the Fairbank Center
in Harvard talking about this I see this
question and the question I address was
is the Chinese government legitimate and
clearly as you know the different
sources of legitimacy so when people
compare the American government with the
Chinese government they say this is a
comparison within a democratic system
and an authoritarian system and a
democratic system is of course better
than Authority and system and I agree a
democratic system is better than an
authoritarian system but if you go if
you dig one level down and you
look at the functioning of the
government and how it makes his
decisions and you analyze it you may see
that the democratic system may be
performing as a plutocratic system
serving the interests of the people the
tiny elite and leaving thus creating a
situation where I think half your
population hasn't seen an increase in
his median income for 40 years
that's what plutocracy is the Chinese
system is a meritocracy the Chinese
Communist Party by the way has got one
of the most amazing meritocratic
selection systems when I had a research
assistant that works out a story many
levels process when I had a research
assistant in Columbia University a few
weeks ago she told me and she was
obviously one of the brightest students
she said she was very disappointed when
she left high school because she said
when you graduate from high school in
China that top student one student is
selected to join the Communist Party and
you want to be that one student selected
to join the Communist Party and then in
the first year and university she says
five students are selected to join the
Communist Party again the top students
so can you imagine the system which
tries to select the best brains to run
the country now the Chinese Communist
Party is not perfect it has a lot of
flaws in making lot of mistakes
by in terms of harvesting the brainpower
of China it has done an amazing job and
I tell the story you know I was in
diplomacy for 33 years when I started my
career in 1971 if you had asked me do
you want to talk to an American diplomat
or Chinese diplomat I would say of
course and talk to American diplomat is
graduate of Princeton Yale Harvard
brilliance the New Yorker every week
knows what's going on the world the
Chinese diplomat 1971 would walk around
with a mouse little red book in his
pocket and when I talk to him you'll
produce mouse read book and read to me
of a mouse read book why should I waste
my time Chinese that's empty one you
fast forward to 2018 and you ask me to
fly to a capital somewhere and you said
you want to talk to the American
ambassador or the Chinese ambassador
the likelihood is that the Chinese
ambassador would speak the language of
the country would have been posted there
several times would have a very new and
sophisticated view of the country and
the American ambassador would be one
who's demoralized knowing that his
budget is being cut knowing his chances
of becoming an ambassador and the top
capital is practically zero because
there are political appointees so you
have a demoralized the American
diplomatic service and an incredibly
dynamic Chinese Foreign Service that's
what that's a big change that has
happened since 1971 and that's a result
of meritocracy and I can tell you you'll
be quite amazed how good some of these
Chinese diplomats are today and it's not
supposed to happen in a closed
authoritarian dictatorial system Kevin
Kelley yes what's the role of diversity
will our culture's converge on assertive
universalities in the long run or in a
way get more and more checker
well I think the we are actually I mean
the most exciting thing about our world
that is happening today is that for the
last 200 years there's been a theme of
my remarks you've had one very
successful civilization Western
civilization and the other civilizations
were underperforming but now we're going
to enter a world where we going from
what I call a mono civilizational world
to a multi civilizational
and a Marty civilizational world is
almost by definition a much more
interesting world to live in
and is whether you in terms of diversity
in terms of choice of as you know for a
start you go to any major cities the
choice of cuisines today is amazing the
diversity of cuisines even here in San
Francisco it's quite amazing right so
that's a world that we're going to see
you're going to get diversity of
experience in many dimensions in the
world that's coming and I guess India is
pretty diverse China is I mean China is
everything it's so big and it's so much
there it is diverse in a sense it's been
has been historically kind of tough on
some of the minorities and we're in
China and so on is that the future do
you think are they getting over that or
what's the tension there yeah well I
think I think China clearly has a lot of
challenges handling the at least three
difficult areas Tibet zinc young and of
course Taiwan so those are three
difficult challenges the Chinese have to
deal with and clearly if the Chinese
want to create a happier outcomes they
have to live by what they have
themselves said they should give greater
autonomy to these regions you know but
of course as you know the problem comes
when there's armed struggle mm-hmm right
and right now I'm lucky the armed
struggle in Tibet is not it's not that
but the armed struggle in ching-chong is
pretty bad and that's going to be a big
problem
right and so it's it the Chinese will
have to show a lot of political wisdom
in managing that problem the last
question and it's from Richard Lee says
what the Train is now giving to the
world in terms of its new Silk Road and
initiatives in Africa that you mentioned
infrastructure in the infrastructure is
sort of good for everybody but it's a
huge commitment that most Americans
don't know about that China has been
making to basically link to Eurasia and
to one connected continent both by sea
and across many paths across the yeah I
you know III I mean that there are lots
of positive contributions that China is
making the number one positive
contribution that China is making by the
way is that you know the Chinese that
can technically take the view which is
correct that global warming is not just
due to the new floors of greenhouse gas
emissions from China and India but
because of the spot of greenhouse gas
emissions that the West has put up and
for a long time China and India insisted
that the West should where the main
price and they shouldn't
so when United States went Ramdas had to
walk away from the climate change
agreement I actually thought I was a
frightened that the Chinese would also
walk away from the climate change
agreement the Chinese didn't do so right
and I think that's one of the wisest
decisions that China made not to give up
its commitments to think you know if
they keep the commitments of climate
change it helps the whole world because
Chinese are not going to be number one
industrial power in the world right
number two the infrastructure that China
is building in Asia is going to help
Asia enormous Lee and you know Y if
infrastructure building is very very
critical if you want if you want your
economy to grow you have to build the
roads the railways the ports and
sometimes schools and so on so far the
Chinese are investing in that and and
that's a that's a that's a positive sum
game for the world and and just for your
information I think this Google and
double check I think about 70% of the
incoming Bri investment the China goes
through Singapore and 33 percent of the
outgoing Bri investment goes through
Singapore so Singapore plays a very
critical role in the Bri initiative and
we are playing a critical role because
we see this as something that's going to
benefit the region and similarly I think
we'll also benefit from all this
infrastructural investment and this is
something frankly that the United States
can work with China so when when when
China set up the Asian infrastructure
investment bank it was an unfortunate
decision on the part of the Obama
administration to oppose it and today I
meet more and more Americans including
some very senior ones I can't mention
their names or told me privately that
was a mistake that America should
actually work with China in this area
and if you work with China you actually
help China develop the standards of good
governance that are very high in these
organizations and the Chinese will
welcome that it sounds like more than
the West in a way China feels like it's
got a job to take responsibility for the
well-being of the world is that their
perception of their role now I've heard
this from Kevin Kelley he thinks that
young people well I I would I would
recommend I would recommend to you two
speeches that Xi Jinping gave last year
in January 2017 the first speech was in
Davos the second speech was in the
Geneva and actually I was very heartened
by those speeches because it showed that
the Chinese actually believe that in the
world of tomorrow to go back to the most
boring M word multilateralism the
Chinese actually believe that we need to
strengthen multilateral institutions and
so the going back to Bill Clinton's wise
advice to the Americans
strengthen multilateral institutions
right now Xi Jinping wants to do that so
this is this actually is a moment of
great historic opportunity if America
can make the right decision to actually
collaborate with China to strengthen
global multilateral institutions well
let's see if that happens
thank you for always
[Applause]
[Music]
you